there's been a lot of talk about
pronouns this week first with the aclu
valiantly defending the loudoun county
school system's right to force teachers
to use the preferred pronouns of
students and then with the state
department urging us all to join in
celebrating international pronouns day
as i said yesterday it seems that it's
it's finally becoming apparent to most
people on the right
that this pronoun issue is not the
sideshow that um
many
once thought it was
i mean it is for one thing an attack on
our fundamental human liberties the
worst kind of attack in fact the problem
with the pronoun policy in loudoun
county and with similar policies that
are being adopted and will soon be
adopted in other localities around the
country it's not simply that speech is
being compelled but specifically that
false speech is being compelled
i mean you can only have freedom real
freedom in truth
which is why any attack on real freedom
is also an attack on truth
these are the implications
and i think i hope
that that's now obvious to most people
on the right
but i also hope that anyone who is slow
on the uptake you know those who took a
while to understand the real threats
that all of this seemingly bizarre
infringed stuff poses to our society
i hope they won't make the same mistake
with the clips that i'm gonna play for
you now because here we have uh two more
contributions to society from tiktok
both videos feature young people
teenagers
taking the preferred pronoun concept to
seemingly new extremes
in this first one we find out that some
of these kids are actually identifying
as inanimate objects listen
hello
i am dull
i am one of our object altars
when i front i find it very difficult to
remember things that the body requires
such as how to move
how to blink
how to breathe and how to speak
for the purpose of filming this video
i have meredith co-conscious with me
so that i will not mess up
however
this is the third take
the first two
i forgot to breathe and or speak
i hope this helps you learn
now
doll here has not invented the doll
pronoun concept in fact a handy resource
is the website pronounee.xyz
which lists and explains all of the
different alternative pronouns currently
in existence
and there are a lot of them
pages and pages hundreds and hundreds
from the very first page you can see
that um if you go there it's apparently
popular now to identify as an emoji
many of the pronouns aren't words at all
but pictures other pronouns include um
poison poisons poisons and poison self
i assume those are big pharma's pronouns
please respect them also fay fairy fair
fairies fairy self kitty kitty's kitty
self
stars star star self
and slow sloth's sloth self and on and
on
there's also dem demon demon's demon
self and if you're wondering what a
self-identifying demon looks like
well you're in luck
hi my name is jasper i use day at
pronouns hi my name is lyanna i use the
demon pronouns this video is how to use
our pronouns
so we're going to basically present
three sentences um one of them is going
to have one pronoun the other one's
going to have the other pronoun and the
last one is going to have both pronouns
interchanged
so leona uses they them pronouns in
demon pronouns so the first sentence
would be liana is my partner they are
cute and i am theirs i love them very
much and i hope they love themselves too
for the demon pronouns it would be leona
is my partner d miss q and i belong to
dean i love demon very much and i hope
dean loves demon self too
then interchanging the two would be
leona is my partner
they are cute and i am dooms
i love demon very much and i hope they
love demon self too
she's she that she's going to be a
linguistics professor that's that's this
is what this is what um grammar
teaching language and grammar that's
what that's what it's going to be pretty
soon
and there is something very on the nose
about this in fact in the gospels when
jesus encountered demon-possessed people
they would sometimes go by they them
pronouns because there was more than one
demon infesting the person and so we may
be able to draw some connections and
analogies here
but i'm afraid
that a lot of people on the same side of
the ideological spectrum might see this
sort of thing and make the same mistake
they made with gender ideology more
broadly assuming that it's kind of a
this weird and wacky phase and it's not
anything widespread or serious or worth
our attention
why why are we even paying attention
this is just tick-tock who cares
and in saner times you know in a culture
that hadn't already sunk below the
surface and into the icy depths of
full-on insanity
that would probably be the right
reaction after all demon self over there
is really just a goth kid trying to be
edgy right we had those when i was a
teenager
the only difference is that now tiktok
exists so they have this unfortunate
vehicle to publicize and advertise these
embarrassing phases
except
that's not the only difference
the other difference and it's a big one
is that we now live in a society that
validates legitimizes and encourages
these alternative identities now when i
was a kid
the adults would tell the goth kids that
they were going through a phase they
need to snap out of it or they're never
going to be able to get a job or a
girlfriend
right that's what the adults used to say
to kids going through these kinds of
phases
now the adults stand off on the sideline
in cheerleader uniforms and pom-poms
sometimes literally
cheering the kids on in their delusions
what would otherwise be a phase
what would be something that makes them
look back in a few years and cringe now
becomes an identity
the meaningless
is transformed into the meaningful
the effect is that a generation of kids
soon to be multiple generations
have been plunged into mass psychosis
we are not merely validating mental
illness but creating it
what would be a phase instead becomes
the kernel of a debilitating
lifelong identity crisis
and our culture is there with the water
cans making sure that those seeds are
germinated
there's not going to be any awakening
moment for these kids or at least there
need not be
i hope there is but there's nothing that
would
cause that to happen because we used to
say well wait until you get into the
real world and that'll be a wake-up call
because the real world doesn't work like
this
but there is no real world anymore not
according to the people who run our
society
there is no reality everything's
subjective everything is malleable
nothing is solid there's no firm ground
to stand on
mass psychosis
a generation driven into madness before
they're old enough to drive a car
that's what we're facing
[Music]
nothing less
and i think we need to start treating
this like the
major problem that it clearly is
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated